hello and welcome to a very special
episode of the reuben report direct
message i of course i'm dave rubin today
is september 28
2021 and i say this is a special episode
because this is going to be a very math
intensive episode because we're going to
be talking about trillions of dollars
not millions not billions trillions
possibly gajillions of dollars and we're
gonna go through it we're gonna carry
the one and see if we can make sense of
anything that the ridiculous people in
this administration and their media
cohorts are telling us because a lot of
it
does not make sense and i should tell
you i should preface this entire half
hour episode by telling you that in
seventh grade i got a b plus in math
okay so i know what i'm doing you can
rest assured you're gonna get some
sensible information on today's show uh
yeah today we got four stories for you
we're first starting off with this
ridiculous absolutely
ridiculous 3.5
trillion
t-r-i-l-l-ion
trillion dollar budget that the biden
administration is putting out there and
they're claiming
it won't
add a dime to the deficit and actually
it won't cost anything it won't cost
anything it's actually incredible so
we're going to talk about that we've got
video and it's not just from the
administration it's from their friends
in the media who launder their lives
because of course if something costs 3.5
trillion dollars it doesn't cost zero
dollars
i got a p plus a math seventh grade
people uh next up we got a couple videos
from nba players who are making more
sense on vaccines than fouchy or any
buffoon that you're gonna see on cnn so
we're going to play a couple of videos
on that and i suspect that these two
players in particular could have
problems getting contracts pretty soon
because they're going against the
mainstream narrative
then this lunatic i mean there's just no
other way to describe her this lunatic
governor of new york the woman who
replaced andrew cuomo
she is just completely out of control
firing nurses replacing them with the
national guard
talking about how they'll be no
religious exemptions for vaccines and
that how god
god she knows god and god wants everyone
to be vaccinated and she even has a
little necklace that says vaccinated or
vaccine or something she's insane and
then finally we are bringing back racism
to college campuses where at least in
one college there will officially be
segregated segregated dorms shocker i
know anyway it's going to be a big show
so sit back get your drink of choice and
we're going to make some sense of things
or at least we're going to try to before
i do any of that i want to talk to you
guys about jen yourself you know i
mentioned in a recent interview how when
i look back on my first prageru video
why i left the left which is about five
six years ago already i can see big bags
under my eyes i was under a lot of
stress i wasn't sleeping well you know
bags and puffiness under the eyes are a
problem for millions of american men and
women until now introducing the new
genius cell serum with plant stem cell
technology from chamonix susan from new
jersey wrote i've been using genusl for
a couple months the puffiness around my
eyes is gone even the crow's feet and
small lines have disappeared and haven't
come back
i love your product i use it under my
eyes around my cheekbones and on my
eyelids not only susan folks and with
their immediate effects you'll see
results in the first 12 hours or your
money back they guarantee it order now
and get 50 percent off all januselle
packages during the final days of their
end of summer clearance sale at
lovegeniacell.com
dave that's l-o-v-e-g-e-n-u-c-e-l
dot com slash dave lovegenyasel.com
dave and now back to me okay let's do
math here we go everybody
take a breath because there's a lot of
[ __ ] going to fly your way in the
next few minutes so the democrats and
old joe biden are trying to pass this
3.5 trillion dollar budget now we all
know that they just make up these
numbers nothing is ever paid for we know
that the united states is in a
tremendous amount of debt the debt keeps
growing it doesn't matter how many times
they raise the debt ceiling none of this
math works out properly we also know
that in our own lives you can't just
keep going into debt you can't just keep
spending more money eventually your
credit cards stop working eventually you
know you go to buy a slice of pizza and
you open up your wallet and there ain't
no cash left in there not that we're
gonna have cash much longer or your your
atm card doesn't work you can't just
keep doing that but when you're the
government not only can you just make up
numbers all the time you can always just
steal from whoever you want to steal at
any given moment just take from the
people who are producing for all of your
crazy pet projects so the big pet
project right now is this 3.5 trillion
dollar agenda of the democrats here's
joe biden on how it's not even going to
cost a dime
we talk about price tags
the it is
zero
price tag on the debt we're paying we're
going to pay for everything we spend
so they say it's not you know people
understandably
well you know it started off at six
trillion now it's 3.5 trillion now it's
going to be 2.9
it's going to be zero
zero because in the in that plan
that i put forward and i said from the
outset
i said i'm running to change the dynamic
of how the economy grows
i'm tired of trickle down
the trillionaires and billionaires
are doing very very well you all know
you've all reported it
and in the middle of this crisis
but hard-working people and middle-class
people are getting hurt
and so i provide for for example a tax
cut if you have a child
you get a refundable tax credit
it's reduced hunger in america by 40
percent
literally for children
you have the uh
the whole notion of being able to
provide for
day care for your children getting
people back to school etc it's all paid
for
it's all paid for but a lot of these are
flat tax cuts
that exist within
my proposal
and they're being calculated as if the
cost of of the child care tax credit is
a cost to the government it's not
it's reducing taxes
reducing taxes not increasing taxes
all right you heard it from joe biden as
he made the white power sign right at
the bill beginning of that
3.5 trillion dollars will actually cost
nothing it's truly incredible and you
thought that when they said two plus two
doesn't equal four anymore that that may
not lead us into trouble well here we
are okay so first off it's all complete
nonsense again we don't have any money
we run a deficit in this country in the
first place now what he's saying is 3.5
trillion dollars again it's zero white
power according to those lunatics uh
he's saying that because it's not going
to add a dime to our deficit because
he's just going to take it from rich
people he said that trillionaires and
billionaires are doing just fine for the
record and we we done gone googled it
there are no trillionaires on planet
earth so i don't know what he's talking
about there there are billionaires and
by the way they pay a tremendous amount
of taxes and they often employ thousands
and thousands of people and create
industries and all sorts of jobs that
fuel the economy so that people like joe
biden who've never accomplished anything
other than accumulate political power
can get all of their pet projects paid
for so to be very very clear about this
when the government is saying something
costs zero it means it costs zero
because we're just gonna take
from other people we're gonna take from
people who produce
and we can all argue about how much
those people should pay and they always
say they don't pay their fair share and
we've gone through this a million times
rich people and especially billionaires
but the one percent pay virtually all
the taxes in the united states the
people at the lowest rung don't in my
book which i'm sure many of you read i
hope you've read i'm completely fine
with a flat tax with with marginal
marginal things that would uh offset
that meaning that if you're at the
lowest you don't even have to pay any
taxes and we could do a little bit of a
progressive tax at the top not that it
even makes any economic sense but just
because it would throw a little
something to the lefties not that when
you throw them anything they accept it
they always want more and more and more
but the point is what we have in america
is not an income problem meaning that
the government doesn't have enough money
it's a spending problem right like this
is basic stuff that people don't
understand does anyone in their right
mind think that the government needs
more money to do more stuff like if
you're sitting around in 2021 and just
thinking boy
my life would be a heck of a lot better
if the government had more money
well then i got a bridge to say i don't
even know what to tell you you should
have your head examined go to the
doctor and get an mri something's wrong
with you man maybe you gotta impaled
with something i don't know like the
government doesn't need more money we
should be starving the government right
now it doesn't do much good except lock
us in our houses and tell us when we can
go out and demand we get you know massed
up and vaccinated 18 times and
everything else so they're lying okay
they're lying that 3.5 trillion costs
zero for example how much conor how much
does you love the chipotle how much
would uh say a basic
burrito cost to chipotle
about ten dollars now it costs ten
dollars now connor answer this for me
let's say there was a really rich guy so
i'm ordering my burrito and you say it
costs 10 and i don't want to pay for
that you know why would i want to pay
for my own burrito if there was a really
rich guy in line and i just turned and i
punched him in the face and i took his
money how much would that burrito cost
it would still cost ten dollars yeah
even if you steal other people's money
and pay for something it still costs
something that's not zero okay was ten
dollars does that include the guacamole
that did not include the guacamole all
right you can get guacamole today um the
everything they say is lies but it's not
just that 3.5 trillion dollars now
equals zero it's not that they're not
you know they're adding to the deficit
and all of those things now watch what
happens as this this idiotic meme that
they just made up 3.5 trillion is zero
watch how this trickles through the
media here's the mr potato head show
brian stelter he had washington post
economic correspondent catherine rampell
on and here's what she said why is that
3.5 trillion figure missing
because it doesn't really represent
anything it's this weird shorthand
that's been used but in fact the bill
itself will not cost 3.5 trillion
dollars in the sense that it will be
entirely or at least partly paid for so
the actual cost in terms of deficits
will be smaller than that perhaps even
zero although i think that's unlikely
that woman is an economic analysis for
washington post 3.5 trillion the amount
it costs doesn't represent anything
that's what she said when you buy a
house
you buy a house it's 500 000
you can't say to them well that number
doesn't represent anything i'll give you
zero give it to me these people are
completely insane but you see what they
did there this is what the democrats and
the media do with everything they
launder lies together biden puts out a
ridiculous lying statement right he
knows that it's not true he knows that
it's not true period and he knows by the
way that once you start taking from all
of those people then they're going to
have to adjust their lives and
businesses accordingly and we'll get to
a video uh on jen saki talking about
this in just a sec with more lies but
once they start doing that they may hire
less people they may fire some people
they may not spend as much money there's
a whole series of things that that can
cause to cascade through the economy and
they know it but they won't talk about
it and then they get economic
advisors analysts on cnn to talk to mr
potato to say that the number doesn't
even mean anything because it doesn't
add to the deficit but that's not how it
works if you spend money that's the
amount you're spending no matter who you
steal the money from
here's jen saki who is an extraordinary
liar and disingenuous human being
explaining she's being asked basically
uh well you know if you if you tax the
hell out of these people maybe companies
are going to start you know passing off
some of that new cost to the consumer
which seems pretty legit that's how
things work right supply and demand and
basic economics take a look more than 16
of taxpayers would see their taxes
increase under the the bill that's
approved by the house ways and means
committee will the president sign that
bill
if as it is coming out of that committee
or will he insist on the changes so that
he will maintain his commitment that
taxes won't go up on people making 400
000 a year i have not looked at the uh
document or the report that you have put
out obviously the president or that you
have referenced i should say that the
republicans put out uh obviously the
president's commitment remains not
raising taxes for anyone
making less than 400 000 a year there
are some and i'm not sure if this is the
case in this report who argue that in
the past
companies have passed on these costs to
consumers i'm not sure if that's the
argument being made in this report
we feel that that's unfair and absurd
and the american people would not stand
for that but i will take a closer look
at this report and get you a more
substantive
god
she's so awful
it's unfair and absurd that companies
may pass the cost to the consumer
when they have to pay more taxes so
suddenly they're looking at their books
right and companies are usually
i think i know a little something about
business and i told you about my seventh
eighth grade math class in ninth grade i
took a business class companies look at
their books and they go oh we've got a
certain amount of money coming in we've
got a certain money amount going out
we've got some profit we can do these
things we can grow we can expand blah
blah blah okay that's how
basic business works the idea that if
you take money away from them just to do
whatever your ridiculous pet projects
are if you say to them we're going to
take more of your money you're
succeeding you're producing something
with value which is why you have money
we're going to take more of it to do
whatever we want because we're the
government and we got guns and we can do
it because you can't stop us
do you think they might pass that on to
the consumer do you think the cost of
say cereal or meat or gas
or whatever it is that you like to do
and you like to purchase do you think
the cost of that might go up if the
companies are going oh why are we in
business we're in business to make money
so she's lying and the idea that it's
absurd i mean she also says it's absurd
but that's not absurd what you said it's
you saying it's absurd is absurd it's
not absurd it's absolutely absurd they
are just horrifically awful so to recap
this segment conor here's what we're
gonna do for the uh for the promo today
just to be clear
3.5 trillion dollars does not equal zero
and joe biden made that sign so he's a
white supremacist 3.5 trillion does not
equal zero
it is not absurd to think that if you
tax companies more and individuals more
that prices of things will go up
and also these people are all liars
let's put a bumper on that and send it
out to the interwebs all right next
segment people let's talk a little bit
about vaccines and everything going on
with covert and as i've been saying to
you i'm sort of feeling lately that
because it's very obvious that covet is
never going away it's going to be this
constant crudgel that they can always
use to control us and and
lock us down and put more rules on us
and
all of the stuff that you all get right
since they're always going to do that i
feel like if i talk about it a little
bit less maybe it'll give it a little
less oxygen and if you guys just go
about your life
as you see fit maybe that's the only way
we we get past this thing it's not going
to be a top-down thing where they
suddenly start saying to us oh you can
you can have your life back
but there were two interesting videos
that i saw this morning from nba players
talking about vaccines and we know by
the way that there are many many i don't
know if we have specific numbers on it
yet are there are there specific numbers
on nfl and nba and mlb players taking
vaxes um but we know that there are a
ton of professional athletes who don't
want to take the vaccines right these
are people usually in their early 20s
mid-20s who are at the peak of physical
performance right who eat right who
exercise who take care of themselves who
we all wish uh we could basically uh
and look like and live that kind of life
and a lot of them are saying we don't
want to get vaccinated actually
michael's showing me some numbers right
now in the nfl it appears that 93
are vaccinated i mean we'll see what
happens to those other seven percent but
there were two videos yesterday that are
going viral right now this first one is
orlando magic player jonathan isaac
talking about vaccines talking about
immunity and everything else and just
listen to this video it's about a minute
long and you tell me who makes more
sense this guy or fouchy uh what is it
about the vaccine that that makes you
uh
hesitant to to to get it uh i i would
start with um i've had kovit
in the past and so our understanding of
antibodies of natural immunity has uh
changed a great deal from the onset of
the pandemic and is still evolving um
i understand that the vaccine would uh
um
help if if you catch covet and uh you'll
be able to have less symptoms um from
contracting it but with me having covert
in the past and having antibodies um
with my current age group and a fitness
physical fitness level um it's not
necessarily a fear of mine
uh taking the vaccine
like i said it would decrease my chances
of
having a severe reaction but it does
open me up to the albeit rare chance but
the possibility of having an adverse
reaction to the vaccine itself
um i don't believe that being
unvaccinated means infected or being
vaccinated means
uninfected you can still catch covet um
with or we're not having the vaccine
um
i would say honestly the the craziness
of it all in terms of not being able to
say that it should be everybody's fair
choice without being demeaned or um
talked crazy to doesn't uh make one
comfortable to do what said person is uh
telling them to do
um
yeah i would say that's that's a couple
of the reasons that um you know i would
say i'm hesitant at this time but at the
end of the day
i don't feel that it is um you know
anyone's reason to come out and say well
this is why or this is not why it should
just be their decision and um
you know loving your neighbors not just
loving those that that agree with you or
look like you are
moving the same way that you do it it's
a you know loving those who don't
gosh isn't that refreshing
not only the information of what he's
saying that he had coveted he talks
about natural immunity talks about the
fact that just because you haven't been
vaccinated doesn't mean you
automatically
have covid um all of that stuff but just
the tenor and tone with which he speaks
right that is a good decent man we are
so uh bereft we're so void at this point
of good decent people on television or
in in the thought leader space that when
you hear someone just a decent guy this
is an nba player we just checked the
stats he's averaged about ten points a
game he's been in the league for a
couple seasons i actually never heard of
him i don't watch the nba anymore as you
know because of the politics that
they've injected into the league so i
don't even know who he was
but like that's a good man like that's
somebody i would like to have dinner
with and chat with um and he talks about
mutual respect and everything else at
the end and it's like which message is
that not a message that we should be
hearing more of right which message are
we always getting you better do what we
say or you're evil or you're racist or
you're an anti-vaxxer or a conspiracy
theory here is a decent man telling you
the truth telling you the absolute truth
we've got another video actually from
another nba player this is washington
wizards player and i did know of him
because he's been playing for a couple
years now bradley beal
every player every person in this world
is going to make their own decision for
themselves um
i would like an explanation to you know
people with vaccines why are they still
getting coveted
if that's something that we are supposed
to highly be protected from like it's
funny that oh it reduces your chances of
going to the hospital
it doesn't eliminate anybody from
getting covered
right so everybody is everybody in here
vax
i would assume right
so you all can still get covered right
we're less likely to die or go to the
hospital
okay but
you can still get covered
right
so and you can still pass it along with
the vax right
i'm not as i'm just asking the question
oh sure until like they're having fun
around the world
basically you're saying like i don't put
words in your mouth but having it
change your opinion one way or another
like did it kind of re-emphasize i don't
need the back saying
no no no
no no no
no that didn't that wasn't the case i
mean
yeah i had it but that doesn't mean i
can't get it again you know
i mean it's no different than somebody
with a vaccine like i can yes i
developed antibodies for it so my
chances will be less likely now as well
right but
it's still a possibility i may get it
just like there are players and coaches
and
staff who are vacs and
missing camp right now because of its
own
bradley beal of the washington wizards
who you saw right there is asking better
questions than anyone in the press corps
is asking of this administration
even when he says the line there he goes
i'm just asking a question
didn't that feel kind of interesting to
you because we're kind of being told at
this point that we can't ask questions
we better
just obey but his questions
are completely valid much like his
commentary is completely valid in
america i think
for a limited time remaining we're still
allowed to ask questions you're still
allowed to question authority you're
still allowed to push back you're still
out to say i am an autonomous individual
and i can make decisions for myself i
wonder
uh how much longer these two guys will
be in the nba because the nba is not too
kind to people who push back right the
nba has made it very clear that they are
a political organization backing black
lives matter that you're not allowed to
talk anti-china and i wonder if it's
going to be a little harder for those
guys to get contracts right now which is
why so many people are silent we did get
a little more info on the vaccinated
percentages of uh professional athletes
i said before the nfl 93 vaccinated mba
it appears 90 percent vaccinated but
also keep this in mind not only are
these guys at the the height of physical
fitness and all of that and eat right
and all the things that you're supposed
to do that we don't talk about anymore
right we don't talk about diet we don't
talk about exercise we just tell you to
stay home and order in chinese food all
of that not only is that all true but
the absolute farce that sports has
become where coaches wear masks when
they're on the sideline and guess what
happens then they call a timeout and
everyone huddles around and the coach is
screaming with the mask so he always
takes the mask down we've all seen these
videos or players they play in the game
they're sweating on each other spitting
on each other bleeding on each other
hacking each other scratching each other
and everything else that's fine on the
court then they get on the bench they
put the mask on it's all nonsensical
theater might i recommend a movie i
don't know if any of you heard of this
movie have you guys heard of this wizard
of oz did you guys hear you've heard of
this it's an old one there was a movie
once called a wizard of oz and i don't
want to blow the whole thing for you but
at the end of the movie
they pull the curtain back and the odds
guy the scary all-powerful oz guy he's
just this old failed wizard
scientist something okay did i give away
too much there's also there's also some
midgets in it there's a yellow brick
road oh wait can't say midgets little
midgets little people small
dwarfs what are they the
the munchkins the munchkins yeah so
they're in it too
you should see it also you should google
actually as long as we're doing this you
should google i'm not if i'm not
mistaken i think i saw this on tmz years
ago the
munchkins when they were filming wizard
of oz
were actually having orgies at the hotel
there were munchkin orgies at the hotel
i can't say orgies oh we just got
demonetized i probably just blew up well
that's it guys we're done anyway that's
a sidebar the point is i like these two
guys i hope they continue to play and we
should be allowed to ask questions and i
pretty much i'm sure the viewership just
dropped because now i've got all of you
googling munchkin orgy which don't do
that just don't do that okay let's talk
about
just there
reset dave here we go
uh let's talk about what's going on in
new york because as you guys know i was
off the grid for august and during
august um
andrew cuomo the governor of new york
had to step down because of all the
endless sex scandals that he was
involved in and when adam corolla
brought me back on the grid on september
1st i was actually shocked when he told
me because i really had felt that sort
of months had gone by and it seemed like
he really was going to skate free on any
of this stuff
as you guys know my feeling on
accusations of course are just that they
are accusations and unless there is
proof then just because someone says
something about you doesn't mean it's
true and we live in this endless cancer
culture thing which it's very dangerous
that we're all getting destroyed by
accusations in any event andrew cuomo
stepped down and before we show any of
the video of the new
new york governor kathy hoechel and this
woman is completely psychotic i want to
show you what i said on september 1st i
had never heard of this woman before but
this is when adam carolla told me that
andrew cuomo had stepped down
with lieutenant governor of work is but
i'm going to guess it's probably
somebody worse i assume is it someone
just like further left yeah
all right so my guess on september 1st
without even knowing who she was is that
she probably was someone worse and
probably someone further
left now
i think i've been proven right we've got
a couple videos of governor kathy
hoechel who keep in mind nobody voted
for
she's firing hospital staff in new york
and replacing them with national guard
if they are unvaccinated so we went
quite literally from two weeks to
flatten the curve to a year and a half
later firing nurses in the name of
health take a look and we'll be nation
leading with our
mandate which strikes at midnight
tonight when everyone is expected in a
hospital in the state of new york or a
health care facility to have been
vaccinated i will be signing an
executive order to give me the emergency
powers necessary to address the
shortages where they occur that's going
to allow me to
deploy the national guard who are
medically trained
deploy people
who've been retired who may have had a
licensed lapse bring in people from
elsewhere that is not my first position
of my friends my my desire is to have
the people who've been out there
continue to work in their jobs working
them safely and to all the other health
care workers who are vaccinated they
also deserve to know that the people
they're working with will not get them
okay so just to be very clear about this
these are trained medical professionals
doctors nurses other people who work in
the hospital who've decided to make some
decision for themselves right they all
made a decision using whatever faculties
they have to figure out what's best for
them and their families these people i
think we've been told they are heroes
and they've worked very hard and they
put their lives on the line and
everything else this crazy woman this
authoritarian lunatic basically just
fired all these people at the stroke of
midnight again nobody voted for this
woman and i wish i wasn't correct on
september 1st about her being worse than
cuomo but obviously i was correct um but
if you think that's not bad enough that
she's saying to these people and just
wait even putting that aside putting all
of that aside if we're to believe
hospitals are crumbling and there's dead
people everywhere and i know we don't
see any videos of this right we don't
see overloaded morgues we don't see any
hospitals falling anywhere no village in
kenya has collapsed we don't see any of
it but they keep telling us it's
happening but if any of that was true
wouldn't you be saying you know what
we've got to keep the nurses no matter
what do they have any evidence please
i'm a guy of science can somebody point
me to any evidence of a doctor or a
nurse transmitting covid at a hospital
to an otherwise healthy person can
anyone show me that i'm guessing that
you can't but if you don't think this
woman is completely insane
now she's also telling us that the
vaccine is from god
i prayed a lot to god during this time
and you know what god did answer our
prayers he made the smartest men and
women the scientists the doctors the
researchers he may then come up with a
vaccine that is from god to us
and we must say thank you god thank you
and i wear my vaccinated necklace all
the time to say i'm vaccinated
all of you
yes i know you're vaccinated you're the
smart ones but you know there's people
out there who aren't listening to god
and what god wants you know this
you know who they are
i need you to be my apostles i need you
to go out and talk about it and say we
owe this to each other we love each
other
jesus taught us to love one another and
how do you show that love but to care
about each other enough to say please
get vaccinated because i love you i want
you to live i want our kids to be safe
when they're in schools i want you to be
safe when you go to a doctor's office or
to a hospital and are treated by
somebody you don't want to get the
virus from them you're already sick or
you wouldn't be there we have to solve
this my friends
i need every one of you i need you to
let them know that this is how we can
get fight this pandemic come back to
normal and then start talking about the
real issues that we have to fighting
systemic racial injustice which exists
today and if there's a denier i will
take you on any day because i've seen it
i know it
you know when i was home in new york
last week i was chatting with my mom and
she watches the show every day she
enjoys the uh the reuben report program
that we do here but she said to me you
know uh david she calls me david she
said david you know you could
occasionally watch the language uh you
know you know you drop the f word every
now and again you can watch a language
with uh
you know sometimes on the show mom if
you're watching right now i need you to
pause this uh or mute it for just a
second
you got it mom that woman kathy hoechel
the governor of new york is a
authoritarian psychotic [ __ ] there's no
other way to put it like i don't know
how you can say anything how dare she
the way she's twisting god and religion
for her own political
motives it's actually disgusting and if
you don't think it's disgusting here's a
little more
from kathy hoechel
my default position is to ask people
please do this
this is why
it's been proven to be safe the
vaccine's been out there a long time now
there are not legitimate religious
exemptions because the leaders of all
the organized religions have said
there's no legitimate reason and we're
going to win that in court in a matter
of days
and so this is so unnecessary
i just want to appeal to the individuals
to know that you know your co-workers
want you to do this
don't make the burden heavier on them as
well
guys your co-workers want to do it
someone else wants you to do something
so if you want to be a good person you
better do it and they're going to beat
the religious institutions in court i
mean there's an assault on religion too
which is a whole other topic although i
guess it's not that whole other because
it's happening right now in front of our
faces this is not a good woman you know
i want to loosely quote something that
dennis prager has been saying probably
for about 20 30 years you know he often
says that the right thinks that the left
is wrong
and the left thinks that the right is
evil and i really think we're getting
into a place where
i can only say that these people are
evil at this point if you lie about
absolutely everything if you lie about
vaccines if you lie about math
if you lie about
systemic racism and the founding of this
country if you lie about everything and
that is what these people do they don't
lie about some stuff they lie about
everything and if you lie about
everything i'm pretty sure that comes
remotely close to the definition of evil
so i don't like looking at my political
opponents my ideological opponents and
thinking that they're evil but someone
like her is evil
at this point i don't know how else you
can you can
deduce it and and it's also reminding me
of of an idea that i've been wanting to
put out there lately which is you know
we often talk about okay there's
conservatives and there's liberals and
there's right and there's left and all
of those things but really what i'm
starting to come around to is there's
two types of people in the world right
another version of this would be that
you know it's it's really authoritarians
versus libertarians you know people that
want to control people and people that
just want to be free but another way you
could look at this i think and we're
really seeing it burst forth in
everything right now is that there's two
types of people there's a type of person
i would include myself in this and i
think you guys in this that wants to
understand the world like the world
exists as it is and we want to
understand it and then manage our lives
in it the best that we can and then
there's another type of person who wants
to control the world they want to manage
the world they want to make the world
and reality bend to their view
that's what we're fighting right now i
don't want to make the world bend to my
view but i want to be able to live in it
in a functional way that's congruent
with my beliefs right
these people want to control the world
and that also and this is what jordan
peterson has talked about for a long
time that also is connected to something
having to do with belief humans need to
believe it in something and once you
remove belief
all you end up with is this secular
nonsense where she's talking she was
excited when she said it that she's
going to court to stop the religious
exemptions
because she's just chosen to believe in
pure rampant secularism and science even
though if you ask that lunatic if
there's a biological difference between
men and women she would say no so it's
like man we got work
to
do and i guess you know what why not
throw to it again
i knew it was coming i knew it was
coming i'm a wise
man i knew it was coming with lieutenant
governor uh
but i'm gonna guess it's probably
somebody worse i assume is it someone
just like further left yeah
all right guys we got one more story for
you today uh racism it's everywhere
racists are everywhere they're coming
for you
you thought we conquered racism well
it's back baby and now it's cool
uh western washington university this is
from fox news uh they've designated the
fourth floor of
alma clark glass hall as housing
reserved for its black affinity housing
program becoming the latest school to
adopt such a program the university
hosted a webinar in april on the subject
saying the segregated living space gives
the students to the opportunity to live
in a shared space with others who have a
shared identity specifically a
marginalized identity the controversial
program segregating student housing
based on race has been adopted at some
other colleges including the university
of colorado at boulder stanford
university and cornell university so i
don't think we have to belabor the point
here
the people who purport to be the
anti-racists the people who are for
diversity and inclusion are actually
for discrimination and exclusion the
idea that we would send
young people our future leaders to
colleges where they should segregate
themselves where they should do the
reverse of what the civil rights
movement was all about that they should
only be around black people if they're
black thus only allowing white people to
be around white people right if you keep
telling all the black kids hey you got
your own thing over there well then
you're gonna suddenly have a white
dorm do we want a white dorm wouldn't
that be racist and by the way if you
just play all this stuff out if you just
play this out over 10 20 years and we
keep
having diversity and inclusion programs
and it keeps getting easier to hire
people or you have to hire people
because they're gay or black or have a
limp or whatever it might be
do you think at some point then the
average just decent kid who happens to
be say a straight white christian male
do you think that then would start
counting as discrimination against him
and then should he start getting
benefits do you see why this would take
us on the road to hell but this is what
these people have brought it's really
quite insane and i hope that most of you
if you're watching this and you're in
college you would not
partake in such a program but i think
the bigger issue is that
once again what are the answers like
what's the answer if we just talk about
this okay so now you're watching this
and you're going boy that's that's
pretty racist and that's pretty stupid
and all that stuff and i won't send my
kids there but that's kind of not enough
and it's not enough for me to just talk
about it what would be enough is that we
must be building new things let's be
building new education systems let's let
cornell be racist let's let stanford be
racist we can't stop them they want the
institutions they got the institutions
they got basically all of them so let
them have them build continue to build
all your crappy things continue to bring
in students not based on skill but on
these immutable characteristics which
will ultimately destroy the academic
level of your system of your school and
then the rest of us will hopefully build
new businesses and new schools and new
technology companies and all of that
stuff i know i know i know this is white
supremacist stuff you know i'm saying
that white people and black people and
gay people and straight people
asian people jew and gentiles should all
be in the same dorm together you know
thus white supremacy uh guys in closing
part one of my interview with jack
is up right now he's got a new
children's book out this guy is a
chinese he's a china analyst a really
interesting guy he runs human events and
he's working with turning point right
now it's a really really interesting
interview part one is up right now
and uh we are now doing live chat
through all of our live streams so right
now in the locals community
reubenreport.locals.com people are
chatting people are chatting with each
other talking about what i'm saying if
you'd like to join us uh it's
reubenreport.locals.com
all right busy day for me i think i'm on
am i on fox later today we got a fox
thing what am i doing later today
i'm on sean spicer over on newsmax i
think that's around three o'clock my
time i think the fox thing maybe got
moved to tomorrow all right have a great
day everybody and remember no matter
what they tell you 2 plus 2 equals 4
and 3.5 trillion doesn't equal 0.
goodbye
you